cette explosion est la plus meurtrière
en france dans une usine pétrochimique
depuis 15 ans depuis plusieurs années de
nombreux habitants des quartiers situés
à proximité du site avait alerté les
autorités sur les risques d'accident le
reportage de pierre nicolas et xavier de
pertes un blessé passe son chemin encore
hébété des heures après l'explosion les
forces de l'ordre tentent par tous
d'organiser la circulation des
commerçants s'affairent sur leur
devanture éventrée après la surprise on
veut faire bonne figure mais ce soir
c'est la colère qu'on sent poindre et
parfois le sentiment d'abandon il se
courir ni psychanalyse
mais il ya des gamins partout et vous
faire part toute menace de s'effondrer
vous allez avoir les balcons et sap
il ya personne et je trouve ça
lamentable dans toute la zone touchée
par la déflagration commerçants et
habitants sont convaincus que ce drame
aurait pu être évité
certains composés c'est les risques aux
villes admissible que la ville elle-même
sache qui se passe dedans et les laisse
continuer ne ferme pas lusine le temps
que les normes soient mises en place il
ya très très longtemps on avait fait des
pétitions un autre voisin parce qu'on
sentait toujours l'ammoniac on avait
fait monter la cheminée de 10 m
l'ammoniaque dans certains pavillons
outre les vitres brisées les toits se
sont effondrés
la mère de cette habitante était dans
cette chambre deux minutes avant que le
plafond ne tombe
cette fois on a évité le pire il faut
maintenant s'occuper de trouver des
bâches se reloger d'urgence et éviter
les cambriolages toute la nuit des
gardiens surveilleront des
rez-de-chaussée ouvert à tous les vents